für den knusprig ist lecker
[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute wieder
unseren alljährlichen Plätzchenteller in
den vergangenen Jahren habe ich immer
wieder Inspiration gezeigt oft auch wie
aus einem Teig mehrere unterschiedliche
Plätzchen zubereiten könnt und heute
habe ich mir gedacht mache ich auch
wieder so etwas ähnliches aber wieder
mit anderen Varianten und auch farblich
so ein bisschen anders einfach und ich
mache dafür erstmal meinen Basis Teig
ich schreibe euch alle ganz genauen
Mengenangaben wie immer hier unten in
die Infobox könnt euch einen Screenshot
machen einkaufen gehen und das ganze
einfach nachbacken ich starte jetzt mit
der zimmerwarmbutter die habe ich zwei
Stunden vorab aus dem Kühlschrank
genommen und schlag sie in der
Küchenmaschine zusammen mit Zucker und
Vanilleextrakt drei bis vier Minuten
lang richtig schön hell cremig
[Musik]
so die butterzucker Masse ist jetzt
richtig schön cremig richtig schön soft
geschlagen worden wenn ihr jetzt keine
Küchenmaschinen habt nehmt ihr eure
Handrührgerät allerdings verdoppelt sich
dann die Zeit weil das geht natürlich
ein bisschen schneller es ist
leistungsstärker mit dem Handrührgerät
einfach mehr Zeit einplanen so jetzt
habe ich hier Backpulver und mehlig
verrühre das jetzt vorab miteinander und
sieht das dann mit zur Buttermasse und
dann auch noch mal so lange unteren bis
sich ein homogener Teig daraus bildet
[Musik]
zu wischen drin die Eier nicht vergessen
mit einzurühren dass wir mir jetzt was
passiert also Eier noch mit reingeben
falls also ich habe jetzt Eier der
größte m falls ihr Eier der Größe S habt
dürft ihr gerne mit einem Schluck Milch
nachhelfen ihr werdet merken dass es
schon so eine sehr weiche samtige Masse
ist also nicht zu trocken nicht
Mürbeteig mäßig also es ist ein
Mürbeteig aber er ist jetzt gerade noch
sehr sehr weich und gleich wenn wir den
kühlen dann wird der noch ein bisschen
fester so ich knete den jetzt hier auf
meiner Silikonmatte noch mal ein
bisschen geschmeidiger und dann teile
ich ihn ähm ich muss mal gucken wie viel
durch wie viel ist es hat ein bisschen
spontan und dann wird er auch schon
eingefärbt und aromatisiert
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt den großen Teig einmal
durch 3 geteilt also zweimal
durchgestochen und das macht einfach
nach Augenmaß es muss nicht perfekt sein
so jetzt nehme ich mir mein erstes
Drittel und da kommt das Backkakao rein
das ist der stark entölte Kakao einfach
einkneten bis sich der Teig braun färbt
[Musik]
so mein Teig ist jetzt schön braun und
ihr müsst jetzt auch nicht extra Milch
dazu geben es sei denn ihr merkt dass er
sehr trocken wird an sich ist es aber
schon sehr feuchter Teig daher ist es
jetzt erstmal nicht notwendig und jetzt
nehme ich mir eine Vorratsdose ihr könnt
auch Frischhaltefolie nehmen ich nehme
jetzt einfach die Vorratsdose den Deckel
drauf und dann muss der Teig 30 Minuten
kühlen was ich auch schon machen kann
dass ich gebe den in den Kühlschrank was
ich auch machen kann ist hier schon mal
von meinem hellen Teig da auch schon mal
die Hälfte weg tun in die
Frischhaltedose
mache ich so genau und dann kommt das
auch schon mal in die Frischhaltedose
weil der bleibt hell finde ich ja auch
süß muss ja nicht alles farbig sein so
das packe ich dann gleich in den
Kühlschrank und werde hier jetzt noch
mal die andere Hälfte vom hellen Teig
mit Matcha Pulver und grüner
Lebensmittelfarbe dann nehme ich heute
Pistazien grün aus meinem Shop einmal
einfärben und der dritte Teig das letzte
Drittel wird dann rot dann nehme ich
einfach rote Lebensmittelfarbe was
nämlich da dann nämlich brombeerrot
genau
[Musik]
so es geht los mit unserem ersten Teig
ich nehme jetzt erstmal den kakaoteig
der konnte jetzt gut durchziehen und ist
auch ein bisschen fester geworden ah
mein ausrollstock mein ausroll starb
einen Moment so ich habe jetzt meinen
ausbaustab mit den abstandsringen und
jetzt müsst euch überlegen wie dick ihr
das wollt nicht zu dick würde ich sagen
wichtig ist halt wenn sie gleichmäßig
dick ausgerollt werden wenn sie auch
gleichmäßig im Ofen gab dann habt ihr
nicht ein der zu dick ist und noch ein
paar Minuten länger braucht das nämlich
voll der Stresssituation vor der Kamera
6 mm Nummer 6 mm nein das ist mir zu
dick wir nehmen einfach drei also einmal
nehmen einmal den kakaoteig ausbreiten
und dann ausstechen ich mache aus dem
Kakao Tag zwei verschiedene Varianten
einmal einen Kreis wo ich den inneren
Kreis aussteche und dann später mit
Kuvertüre und einmal ein schönes
Ornament da mache ich dann vielleicht
Haselnusskerne oder so drauf
[Musik]
mein erstes Blech habe ich jetzt erstmal
zehn Minuten in den Kühlschrank gestellt
das ist ganz wichtig dass das einfach
alles ein bisschen fester wird und nicht
ganz so verläuft beim Backen und das kam
dann anschließend bei 180 Grad Ober und
Unterhitze in den vorgeheizten Backofen
die Kekse brauchen 10 bis 12 Minuten je
dicker ihr sie ausrollt desto länger
brauchen Sie natürlich und denkt dran
frisch nach dem Backen kann man sie
nicht anheben sie würden zerbrechen ähm
sie backen halt immer noch ein bisschen
nach auf dem Blech und werden dann erst
nach dem Abkühlen fest und dann
dekorieren wir sie auch so als nächstes
ähm während die Schokokekse Backen nehme
ich mir die Matcha Kekse jetzt schon mal
auf meine Silikonmatte Roll sie dann in
gleicher dicker aus also ich nehme auch
wieder drei oder soll ich mehr nehmen
nicht in drei Millimeter oder sie mich 6
Tage ich glaube ich nehme diesmal sechs
und dann brauchen Sie mit Sicherheit 12
vielleicht auch 13 Minuten und dann
werde ich mir einfach so Tannenbäumchen
ausstechen
[Musik]
so aus dem hellen Teig habe ich jetzt
Herzen ausgestochen natürlich auch auf 6
mm denn wenn ihr euch dafür entscheidet
sollte das ganze Blech die gleiche Dicke
haben damit es auch gleichmäßig gar
gebacken wird und jetzt kommt es auch
wieder für mindestens 10 Minuten in den
Kühlschrank ihr könnt wenn ihr mein
Blech zu Hause habt könnt ihr die Seiten
noch einfahren dann ist das Blech noch
kleiner ähm bei mir passt das jetzt aber
und nach den 10 Minuten bei gleicher
Temperatur für ca ich würde sagen
aufgrund der Dicke 12 bis 13 Minuten
backen und ich mache eine Zwischenzeit
weiter mit dem Bordeaux roten Teig bis
gleich
[Musik]
während die letzte Ladung Kekse zum
Backofen ist werde ich hier meine
Kuvertüre vorbereiten ich nehme heute
Vollmilch Kuvertüre und weiße wir können
auch Zartbitter nehmen allerdings
sollten wir sie jetzt temperieren das
heißt schön fein hacken dann zwei
Drittel einfach nach Augenmaß zwei
Drittel hier schon mal in die
schmelzschale geben und dann ein
Wasserbad vorbereiten das habe ich hier
schon gemacht einmal Wasser schön
aufkochen lassen danach gehe ich runter
bzw kann auch den Herd komplett
ausschalten und dann kommt der
schmerztopf einmal hier auf den
richtigen Topf das Wasser sollte den
Schmelztopf jetzt nicht berühren da
sollte so ein bisschen Luft zwischen
sein einfach damit sie ganz langsam vor
sich hin Schmerzen kann zwischendrin
könnt ihr mit dem Teigschaber immer
wieder verrühren und dann erst gebt ihr
wenn sich alles zusammengeschmolzen hat
geb dir das letzte Drittel dazu dann hat
es einfach die perfekte Temperatur hat
kein Grauschleier ist perfekt zum
weiterverarbeiten und das gleiche
Prinzip machen wir auch mit der weißen
Kuvertüre
[Musik]
so meine Kuvertüre ist geschmolzen ich
habe jetzt hier ein Spritzbeutel bzw ich
nehme mir zwei ein für die dunkle und
einen für die weiße Kuvertüre und dann
einfach einfüllen vorne die Spitze
abschneiden und dann werden die Kekse
verziehen ihr könnt jetzt noch Pistazien
Haselnusskerne Marmelade oder Kiki
Screams ihr könnt alles mögliche dazu
nehmen ich werde jetzt einfach
Impressionen einblenden und dann könnt
ihr euch davon inspirieren lassen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so ich sehe schon das wird ein richtig
schöner bunter Plätzchenteller ich habe
jetzt hier das meiste mit weißer und
Vollmilchkuvertüre gemacht hier noch mal
Pistazien mit rein gegeben dann habe ich
die geröstete Kokosnuss
Haselnuss Krokant und jetzt habe ich ja
hier noch die bordeauxroten da habe ich
mir überlegt bei den Sternen nehme ich
auch wieder weiße Kuvertüre was nämlich
da und top als Topping vielleicht auch
wieder irgendein Nuss weil ich mag das
nicht so crunchy ist und bei den anderen
da mache ich so ein Doppeldecker quasi
wie beim Prinzenrolle und gibt da eine
cream mit rein so und jetzt ist er ganz
neu ich weiß gar nicht wenn das Video
online ist ob die schon verfügbar ist
ich glaube aber schon
[Musik]
so für die bordeauxroten Ornamente nehme
ich jetzt noch die strawberry cream ich
finde sowohl geschmacklich als auch
optisch einfach perfektes Match und das
gebe ich jetzt einfach hier mein
Spritzbeutel schneidet vorne die Spitze
ab und füll das dann so rüber
Prinzenrolle wie so ein Doppeldecker
[Musik]
warte ich habe gerade genascht so was
von lecker so richtig mürbe aber auch
saftig gar nicht trocken wichtig ist
halt dass sie sie nicht zu lange im
Backofen lässt und einfach kurzzeitig
aus dem Ofen nehmen und sie halten jetzt
luftig verpackt mehrere Wochen das ist
überhaupt kein Problem ich werde jetzt
die Box einmal mitgeben in den Online
Shop damit die Kiki Kuh auch probieren
kann und ansonsten ganz viel Spaß beim
Nachmachen abonniert meinen Kanal
komplett kostenlos wenn ihr solche
Rezepte nicht mehr verpassen möchtet und
dann sehen wir uns auch beim nächsten
Video tschüss eure Kiki jetzt probieren
sondern für ein knusprig ist lecker auf
jeden Fall ja kann man machen
mega perfekt
[Musik]